Bouquet of roses.
Welcome to the world of things,
you're in a dream Surprise!
That's right, this is one of my favorite flowers.
It's said that they floated it and enjoyed
the scent It's good to have the scent of roses in the mud It's
definitely up to you to condense the scent.
Proceed or not
2 The
appearance and texture should be mushy I won't be lazy I
've soaked in the scent of roses, but it's a bit time-consuming After
carefully washing the damask rose petals with water, all at once  Throw it in the pot and make the pink Anma
Aipara syrup.  When you put it in the pond
, the delicate red color and wonderful fragrance of the rose gradually permeates the apple flesh.
Named by Momonashi Chan-
sama's ding tart
This is made of rubber tube so you can eat it Phi
Cute,
cute n